Welcome to the State of the Netherlands
Where the lily flowers
Windmills spin
Breakfast containing chocolate
Majestic people
The sea is trying to submerge it all
But this is not the Netherlands
It is time to know the difference between the Netherlands and Netherland (lowlands) and much more
The correct name for this country of lily flowers
Windmills
Heggles (Dutch eaters)
Activity of container ships
Ocean occupation
The Netherlands is Nethelands
But this confusion is expected as this region has been renamed several times
For thousands of years: the United Republic of Low Lands
United States of America
And the Kingdom of the Netherlands
But it is not history alone
Netherlands is divided into 12 provinces:
Groningen
Drenthe
Overheesle
Hilderland
Lemberg
Norte
Norte Brabont
Zeeland
Which for this reason became the name of New Zealand such as: New Zeeland
Friesland is spotted with beautiful little hearts
Flevoland
Utrecht
Here is the place of confusion: North Holland and South Holland
The two provinces of Tan made Netherlands called the Netherlands
Similar to the naming of Dakota states and Dakota
Which is mostly empty (free of population) and safe for Jacqueline - a kind of wild animal
The two provinces are the most densely populated
Where the most attractive areas such as Amsterdam and Kökenhof
If you have heard of it (ie the International Court of Justice) it is also in one of the Dutch
Even the official government website of the travel guide is www.holland.com
Because it seems more popular but informal
Maybe it's exactly what people are looking for
The mixing continues where the Dutchmen are called Hollanders
But also the citizens of Netherlands are called Dutch
As is the name of their language but in their language they say:
Which they also seem to have instead of Netherlanish
At the same time the counterpart in Germany say:
Which they also seem to have instead of Dutch
This linguistic confusion is the reason why the Americans
They call it Dutch Dutch although German
-Revision-
This country is: Netherlands (Lowlands)
The people of the lowlands
Language of the people of the lowlands
There is no such country as the Netherlands, but the northern and southern provinces of the Netherlands
Is it clear?
Great, because we're getting into more complicated things
Netherlands are part of the kingdom that are of the same name
The Kingdom of Netherland is called by the Royal Family
Which contains three other countries and to identify them
We must sail across the frozen North Sea towards the Caribbean
Where Aruba, Curacao, and St. Martin
These new islands are self-governing within the Kingdom of Netherland
It has its own government and independent cash currency as well
<Side geographic note>
The island of Saint Martin is just the southern half of the small island
The so-called Sainte Martin is also within the Kingdom,
While the other half (northern) is occupied by France and also called Saint Martin
Although they are on the European map separated by the state of Beljika
The Kingdom of Netherland and the Republic of France share the same border
On that island in the other part of the world it's something beautiful
But why did the Kingdom of Netherland arrive in the Caribbean?
Simply put,
- Empire -
In 1600 AD the peoples of the lowlands were always seeking to expand their trade
And to put their hands on everything precious and accessible
For a time, the East Coast of America was called the New Netherland, a new lowland
With its new Amsterdam capital
As well as New Zealand as mentioned earlier and nearby
The queen of the islands (Australia) was called the New Holland A New Holland
Although the empire ended, the three Caribbean islands remained
While four countries within one kingdom are not strange
It does not stop there because the state of Netherland has expanded its borders within the Caribbean
Through 3 other islands: Bonaire, Saint Eustachius and Ceiba
These islands are not one of the Kingdom's states but separate cities under the state of Netherland
The citizens residing there are elected by the government and so on
They do not follow any boycott and deal with the dollar instead of the euro
Somewhat on the quasi-Hawaiian that is not a state
But technically a subsidiary of the province of Colombia as well as dealing in a different currency is the yen
These cities belong to the state of Netherland
These are the countries of the Kingdom of Netherland
All are known as Ditch-Caribe and its citizens are citizens of the Kingdom of Netherland
Because this kingdom is a member of the European Union, that means
These Dutch-Caribbean islands are also European, and in the end.
There are six Caribbean islands, four states, two provinces, two Dutch, two lowlands
And one kingdom, all of them (Dutch)